HEARING OF THE COMMITTEE ON
ARTS ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS
TOURISM IN INTERNET MEDIA TO
ORDER. ON APRIL TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BEFORE WE
BEGIN OUR HEARING OUR THREE
BILLS ARE WE HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS TO COVER DUE
TO THE CURRENT STATHAM ORDER WE
ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE IN THIS HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CAPITOL BUILDING WE HAVE
LIMITED WE HAVE A VERY LIMITED
SPACE IN THIS ROOM FOR PEOPLE
TO WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN
PERSON. AND STILL PRACTICE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
ADDITIONALLY MASTERY ACQUIRED
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM AND AT
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION AT
ALL TIMES. FOR THE PUBLIC TODAY
IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY SEVEN WE
ARE CONDUCTING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING AGAIN
MASKS ARE REQUIRED. IN THIS
CASE WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
SEVEN MEMBERS A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT STAFF AND A LIMITED
NUMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA
SO WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET. OF
SPACE IN THERE ALSO STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND FOR THOSE
THAT ARE HERE TODAY AND THE
HEARING. ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN A BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I WILL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU ARE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCE ST UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU ARE CALLING N. PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOUR TEST OF. YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR PRESENT BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING HIM
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROAD. CAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SELL DISTORTION. PLEASE ALSO BE
ADVISED THAT IF YOUR MAIN
WITNESSES PROVIDING TESTIMONY
FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL. YOU
WILL REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND
WILL NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF INTO
YOU ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. I
ALSO WANT TO KNOW WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK
YOU FOR BEING PATIENT WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT NEW METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. NOW WITH THAT WE ARE
GOING TO ASK FOR COOPERATION
DURING THIS HEARING AND NO
DISRUPTIONS AS WE BEGAN WE HAVE
THREE BILLS- AND WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND AS WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM. WE WILL GO AHEAD IN
BEGAN WITH TESTIMONY AND THEN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AS WE GET
OUR MEMBERS HERE. SO WE ARE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
ONE A. B. THIRTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO. SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY ARE YOU WANT TO
START BY ACCEPTING AS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS- WHAT'S DESCRIBED IN
THE ANALYSIS. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF ON
THE WORKING WITH MY OFFICE- THE
AMENDMENT WOULD CLARIFY THAT.
AN INTERNET BASED SUBSCRIPTION
STREAMING STREAMING SERVICES
NOT A SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM. AB
THIRTY FIVE WOULD REQUIRE
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS TO
DISCLOSE WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE A POLICY IN PLACE TO
ADDRESS ONE. THE SPREAD OF
MISINFORMATION THAT COULD LEAD
TO PHYSICAL HARM TO VERIFIABLE
IN AUTHENTIC CONTENT. AND THREE
PRACTICES THAT DECEPTIVELY
MANIPULATE OR DISRUPT THE
BEHAVIOR OF USERS. SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS FORM AN INTEGRAL PART
OF HOW U. S. ADULTS CONSUME
NEWS. ACCORDING TO THE PEW
RESEARCH CENTER IN 202053% OF
U. S. ADULTS. GOT THEIR NEWS
FROM SOCIAL MEDIA.
ALTERNATIVELY ARE STATISTICALLY
ARE REPORTED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT APPOXIMATELY 50% OF
PEOPLE SHARED A NEW STORY ONLY
TO FIND OUT LATER THAT THE NEW
STORY WAS FALSE. RESEARCHERS AT
UC SAN FRANCISCO FOUND THAT
AFTER ALL FORMER PRESIDENT
TWEETED THE TERM CHINESE VIRUS
WHEN TALKING ABOUT COVERT
NINETEEN THE NUMBER OF TWEAKS
THAT USED THE PHRASE. ROSE BY.
8000310051% NOW SINCE MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY VIOLENT ATTACKS
AGAINST THE ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICANS. COMMUNITY
HAS SKYROCKETED IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE OF MISINFORMATION. SOME
MAJOR PLATFORMS HAVE MADE A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT IN
COMMUNICATING WITH THEIR USERS
AND THE PUBLIC. ON THEIR
EFFORTS IN COMBATING THE SPREAD
OF MISINFORMATION HOWEVER IT IS
NOT CLEAR IF ALL PLATFORMS ARE
DOING THIS AS WELL. AB THIRTEEN
WOULD REQUIRE THAT PLATFORMS
MAKE THOSE DISCLOSURES TO THEIR
CONSUMERS THE BILL DOES NOT
DIRECT HOW PLATFORM SHOULD
CURATE THEIR CONTENT IT ONLY
REQUIRES THE PLATFORM TO GIVE A
DISCLOSURE. AND MAKE IT EASILY
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC. THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND ALSO THE
COUNTY COUNCIL OR THE CITY
ATTORNEY WILL HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE THIS
STATUTE. IF AFTER RECEIVING
NOTICE THE PLATFORM DOESN'T
POST A POLICY THE WILL BE. A
SUBJECT TO A ONE THOUSAND
DOLLAR FINE A DAY. AB THIRTY
FIVE IS NOT AN ONEROUS
REQUIREMENT ON PLATFORMS BUT IT
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO STOPPING THE
SPREAD OF MISINFORMATION. I
HAVE- TWO WITNESSES SO FIRST OF
ALL PROFESSOR- EMERGE AMERICA
SAID JOHN SIMS FROM MCGEORGE
SCHOOL OF LAW. AN EXPERT ON
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW HERE TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY I ALSO HAVE
THE SUBPOENA TECH OR
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL FROM
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND GO TO THE PHONES. ALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JOHN
SAM'S DOT COM EMERITUS
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY
UNIVERSITY THE PACIFIC MCGEORGE
SCHOOL OF LAW MY TESTIMONY
TODAY IS THAT AS AN INDIVIDUAL
BUT AS BACKGROUND I'D LIKE TO
MENTION THAT I WAS A MEMBER OF
THE LAW SCHOOL FACULTY BETWEEN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX AND TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN MIGHT KILL
THE SPECIALIZATION HAS BEEN
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW AND IN
PARTICULAR THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
IN MY VIEW NO SUBSTANTIAL
CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION CAN BE
RAISED ABOUT EIGHTY THIRTY
FIVE. THE BILL DOES NOT
REGULATE SPEECH IT'S A CONSUMER
PROTECTION STATUTE IT MERELY
REQUIRES PROVIDERS OF THE
SERVICE TO INFORM USERS ABOUT
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THE MANNER
IN WHICH THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS OPERATED. THERE ARE
MANY DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
APPLE TO THOSE PROVIDING GOODS
AND SERVICES AT FIRST AMENDMENT
LAW ACCEPTS THIS EVERYDAY
PROCESS OF REGULATION WHICH
PROTECTS AGAINST FRAUD
EXPLOITATION AND OTHER INJURIES.
AB THIRTY FIVE IS LIKE A
REQUIREMENT THAT ONE SELLING A
NEWSPAPER OR MAGAZINE HAVE TO
PRINT THE SALE PRICE ON THE CAR
OR THE FIRST PAGE. SIMILARLY
ONE SELLING SOFTWARE COULD BE
REQUIRED TO PAY FOR PURCHASERS
ABOUT WHETHER THERE WAS A
WARRANTY. IN DEALING WITH
EXPRESSION PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMEN THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE LAW TO BE
MORE PRECISE THAN WHAT IS
EXPECTED FROM ONE OF THE BILL
LEGISLATION. BUT THIS WILL HI
IS QUITE DETAILED. ESPECIALLY
AFTER THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENT.
ARE OVER AT THIRTY FIVE DOES
NOT REGULATE THE CONTENT OF
SPEECH AT ALL IT DOESN'T EVEN
TOUCH UPON THE TIME PLACE AND
MANNER OF EXPRESSION. THE FIRST
AMENDMENT DOES NOT PREVENT
SHOULD CIVIL PROTECTION
DISCLOSURES OF HESE TIGHTS.
AND I AM CONFIDENT. THAT AB
THIRTY FIVE WOULD EASILY
SURVIVE THE FIRST AMENDMENT
CHALLENGE IF ANYONE WOULD RAISE
SUCH AN ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR LISTENING TO MY
COMMENTS. THANK YOU OUR NEXT WE
HAVE SAVANNAH TO KERR FOR- FROM
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA BY TELEPHONE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BEGIN ATTACK OF THE CONSUMER
DURING THE CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
FIVE THE TOPIC OF
MISINFORMATION HAD BEEN HOTLY
DEBATED ISSUE FOR SOME TIME NOW
A DATA SHOWS AMERICANS
ROUTINELY RELY UPON NEWS THAT
THE SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM. THE
FORMAT AS SOCIAL MEDIA REPOSE
IN CLICKBAIT ALLOWS AND
ENCOURAGES FOX NEWS STORY TO
REACH MASS AUDIENCES. SMALL BIG
NEWS ORIGINALLY ORIGINATED AND
ELECTION NEWS NOW STARTED. BUT
CAN DEMOCRATS DIRE CONSEQUENCES.
ASIA OF HOW COULD AT BRAD THE
NUMBER CASES. OF THE VIRUS CAME
THAT ONLY BE CAN START TO
CONTAIN THE SPREAD BUT IT
BUDGET. A CRIME AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS. AT THIRTY FIVE IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP TOWARDS
TACKLING THE ISSUE BUT THE
REASON COULD BE RETURNING TO
THE STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND ALL ASKER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MOTHER EARTH
DAY. THANK YOU- I DO JUST HAVE
A FEW QUICK QUESTIONS IN TERMS
OF CLARIFICATION FOR WHAT THE
BILL ACTUALLY DOES AND WHO. AND
HOW IT IS APPLIED I'M SOUL
WOULD THIS JUST REQUIRE. A
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM. TWO ONE
SEND THAT MSSAGE TO ITS USERS
THOUGHT THEY HAVE A POLICY IN
PLACE AND OR WOULD HAVE TO BE
ATTACHED TO EVERY ARTICLE AND
HOW ARE THEY DOES THE LANGUAGE
DECIPHER THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
AN ARTICLE AND A POST FOR
INSTANCE IF SOMEBODY WERE TO
POST AN ARTICLE- AND LINK THE
ARTICLE YOU CAN CLICK ON THAT.
LINK AND IT GOES TO WHATEVER
ARTICLE FROM WHATEVER MEDIA
DOES AND MEDIA MEDIUM- BUT IF
SOMEBODY WERE TO CUT AND PASTE
AN ARTICLE ON TO THEIR OWN POST
THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT SO
WITHOUT TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION CAN YOU ADD SOME
CLARIFICATION FOR ME SURE
THANKS WE QUESTIONED THE LAW
WILL REQUIRE THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM ITSELF TO POSE. SOME
KIND OF A NOTICE TO THE USER OF
THAT PLATFORM SO- IF YOU SAY
THAT IS A ONE TIME- A SITUATION
THAT IS THE CASE BECAUSE IT HAS
TO BE OF NOTICEABLE IT HAS TO
BE DISPLAYED ARE VISIBLE WAY TO
THE USER SO IT COULD BE- THAT'S
A ON THE FRONT PAGE OF THE
WEBSITE THE END UP YOU KNOW
DOESN'T HELP YOU KNOW THE
ARTICLE WAS RECEIVED OUR
ARTICLES THAT. WOULD BE LINKED
UP FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD THERE
IS NO REQUIREMENT THAT THOSE
ARTICLES HAVE TO BE- YOU KNOW
GIVEN NOTICE AT THE
REQUIREMENTS ON THE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM ITSELF THAT'S A
TWITTER OR OTHERWISE HAVE A
FACEBOOK YOU KNOW THEY USUALLY
HAVE A PIZZA OR COME YOU KNOW
THE OF THE FIRST PAGE OF THE
COVER PAGE. SO THERE HAS TO BE
POST THERE ONCE. THE YOU FOR.
AND I THINK THIS ALSO INCORRECT
REFORM WRONG BUT IT ALSO BUILDS
ON WHAT IS ALREADY BEING
ESTABLISHED- IN THE LAST- IF
YOU WANT TO SAY YEAR OR LONGER
WHERE I KNOW THAT ON SOME OF
SOCIAL MEDIA STORIES AND SO
FORTH SOMETHING MAY COME OUT
AND THEN YOU CLICK IT IT SAYS
THE CONTENTS NO LONGER
AVAILABLE BECAUSE EITHER
THEY'VE ALREADY PUT OUT THAT
IT'S FALL SO SOME OF THE
PLATFORMS ARE ALREADY STARTING
TO DO THIS EVEN WITHOUT THIS SO
THIS JUST FOLLOWS THAT IS THAT
CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT I
THINK. MANY OF THE MAJOR-
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE
ALREADY DOING IT SOME DO MORE
THAN OTHERS AND SOME ACTUALLY-
YOU KNOW I'LL TELL YOU MORE
INFORMATION THAN JUST YOU KNOW
THE BUTTON SAYING THEY DO WHAT
THEY DO NOT HAVE SUCH A POLICY
SO BUT THAT THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED OF
THESE PLATFORMS OUT THERE AND
ONLY CERTAIN MAJOR ONES ARE
DOING TO US SO WE ARE ASKING
THAT ALL PLATFORMS TO THE SAME.
AND AGAIN WE ALSO HAVE TO BE
DILIGENT OURSELVES TO DO YOUR
RESEARCH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- CHAU THANK YOU
I THINK I KINDA UNDERSTAND YOUR
ORIGINAL INTENT THE WHOLE
WHENEVER IN ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION LIKE YOU ARE
SAYING- THE MAJORITY THE MAJOR-
SOCIAL PRODUCTS- PLATFORM SAID
TO HAVE- THEIR DISCLOSURE-
STATEMENT SIR- AND- YOUR INTENT
IS SELF FOR OUR TO- DISCLOSER
THERE ARE POLICY. ORGANIZERS
OUR MY OWN ALICE'S SYSTEM
MECHANISM TO ADDRESS SPREAD ALL
WILL. MISS IN FORMATION- EVEN
THOUGH. BY REQUIRING ALL DAHLE-
PLATFORM SO TO HAVE TO DISCLOSE
AVAIL POLICY. ONCE THE-
DISCLOSE. DOES THAT. ALLOW THEM
TO THIS COMMITTEE ON DEAL OWN
DEFINITION WHAT THE
MISINFORMATION OR BE HOW CAN
YOU DEFINE WHAT I CAN DEFINE
THEM WHAT IS A MISINFORMATION
SO IN OTHER WORDS SO THEY CAN
CHANGE THEIR MIND ANYTIME. THE
AGENCY I TREAT THE ASSESSORS
FOR MISINFORMATION. YOU
MENTIONED- NAY TURN OF IRIS.
HALL HALL HALL CAN YOU'LL RULED
IT THAT DOES SOME
MISINFORMATION IN ALL SAW THAT
WORRIES ME I THINK THERE IS A
VERY IMPORTANT DISTINCTION WE
WANT TO MAKE OF THE BILL ONLY
REQUIRES THE PLATFORMS TO SEE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE SUCH A
POLICY IT DOES NOT ACTUALLY
REQUIRE THE DISCLOSURE OF THE
POLICY- SILVA SO THERE IS IT'S
A MAJOR DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TWO. BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT ASKING THESE PLATFORMS TO
TELL US WHAT THE POLICIES FAR
WE JUST ASKING THEM WHETHER OR
NOT THEY HAVE SUCH A POLICY.
AND AS FAR AS THE DEFINITION
ITSELF IT'S THE IT'S LISTED IN
IN THE LAW ITSELF HOW YOU KNOW
HOW WE DEFINE A MISINFORMATION
IT PASSED TO MEET ONE OF THE
ACT ACTUALLY HAS TO MEET THE
THREE CRITERIA THAT THAT'S
LISTED IN THE LAW- I MEAN JUST
READ HIM OFF LAW SO THEY HAVE
TO ADDRESS THE SPREAD OF
MISINFORMATION THAT THAT
CONTRIBUTES TO THE RISK OF
IMMINENT VIOLENCE. OR PHYSICAL
HARM OR TO REDUCING THE SPREAD
OF HARMFUL VERIFIABLE IN
AUTHENTIC CONTENT IT WAS A
DIFFICULT STORIES AND NUMBER
THREE PRACTICES THAT ARE
INTENDED TO DECEPTIVELY AND
SUBSTANTIALLY MANIPULATE OR
DISRUPT THE BEHAVIOR OF THE
USERS SO IT WOULD HAVE TO MEET
THOSE THREE CRITERIA ARE YOU
KNOW TO CONSTITUTE A
MISINFORMATION IN THIS CONTEXT.
BUT BUT ONCE AGAIN THAT THE
MAJOR DISTINCTION IS THAT WE'RE
NOT ASKING THE PLATFORMS TO
TELL US WHAT THOSE POLICIES ARE
BUT WHICH THIS ASKING THEM TO
TELL US WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAVE SUCH A POLICY. ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES AND THEY HAVE TO
MEET THIS OF THREE CRITERIA
THAT YOU'RE MENTIONING WHAT ARE
THE POLICIES THAT WOULD ADDRESS
THOSE THREE- ALL CONDITIONS
CORRECT BUT WE'RE NOT WE DON'T
NEED TO WE DON'T NEED. TO KNOW
WHAT THOSE POLICIES ARE UNDER
THIS LAW. AND BY THE WAY THE
DEFINITION OF FOR
MISINFORMATION WAS A PRODUCT
OF- THE- THE LAST YEAR YOU KNOW
THE- LAST YEAR'S WORK IN FACT
WE WORK WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
IN COMING UP WITH A DEFINITION
THAT WOULD COVER. YOU KNOW A
LOT OF THE- THE ACTUAL
PRACTICE. OF THE INDUSTRY. OKAY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SO WE HAVE
A QUORUM WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD
AND- TAKE ROLE IN RICK SILVA
HERE QUIKSILVER HERE ABOUT THE
DENNIS NOT MANY. MATHIS WILL
TAKE AN ACTIVE ROLE. CALAVERAS
HERE BLOOM. BLOOM HERE TO. CHOI
YEAH CHOI HERE FRIEDMAN THE
SYRIAN WE HAVE A QUORUM OKAY
AND THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYBODY I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY HERE TO TESTIFY IN THE
ROOM. AND WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
GO TO ANYBODY ON OUR PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OR
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB B.
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN.
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND I SAID NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THE
TIME. ADD ANY COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. COMMENTED. JUST
CHECK IN ARE THERE ANYBODY
ONLINE WHO IS OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
A. B. THIRTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE SEVEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND I
SHOW NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH
AT THE TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK TO THE OFFICE IF
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE- WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
OKAY FOR THE MOTION AND THE
SECOND. FURTHER AN EMOTION IN
THE SECOND AND WE WILL HAVE A
PHANTOM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB THIRTY FIVE CHAU
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUICK SILVA A QUICK SILVA I
ABOUT THE DENNIS. THE LATEST
NOT VOTING BLOOM BLOOM ONLINE
TO. CHOI CHOI NO FRIEDMAN.
NAZARIAN THE BILL PHONE CALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE ON FILE AND I
AM TO AB. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. USE
ADULT ATHLETICS CHRONIC
DRAMATIC. THE FOUR. THE SERVICE
HELLO THE P. I NEVER GET IT
RIGHT SO I'LL JUST SAY C. T. E.
K. I WOULD SAY THAT I WAS GOING
TO SUBJECT FOR THAT. SO THIS IS
ABOUT THE ISSUE YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL NOT YOUTH FLAG
FOOTBALL BUT YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL. IN THE ISSUE OF C. T.
YOU KNOW WE'VE SEEN THE LAST
DECADE OR SO MORE AND MORE
RESEARCH ON THE DANGERS. OF
REPETITIVE TRAUMA TO THE HEAD.
AND YOUTH ESPECIALLY PLAYING
TACKLE FOOTBALL STARTING AT A
YOUNG AGE WE ALL KNOW
COMMONSENSE GETTING HIM THE
HEAD. OVER AND OVER IS NOT A
GOOD THING FOR ANYBODY
ESPECIALLY LITTLE KIDS COME
WITH KIND OF LIKE WE HEAR THE
ISSUE WITH. SHAKEN BABY
SYNDROME- KIDS BRAINS AREN'T
FULLY DEVELOPED AND SO HAVING
REPETITIVE HITS TO THE HEAD.
IMPACTS THE YOU KNOW THE BRAIN.
AND LATER IN LIFE- COULD HAVE
BOB HURRICANE TAXES SOME OF
THESE IN ADULTS WHO GET C. T.
E. SO. JUST AS THERE IS
RESEARCH THAT SHOWS THAT
SMOKING IS BAD FOR EXAMPLE WE
ALL KNOW THAT BUT THE YOUNGER
YOU START SMOKING THE GREATER
YOUR RISK OF GETTING. CANCER
AND OTHER LUNG DISEASE- IT IS
THERE IS THERE IS NO CRYSTAL
CLEAR- YOU KNOW. GOTCHA TYPE
RESEARCH HAS THAT COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AS A STATE BUT THERE
IS. A LEADING RESEARCH OVER AND
OVER AND OVER I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE IMPACTS OF THE AGE THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE START PLAYING
TACKLE FOOTBALL. AND THE
IMPACTS ON PUBLIC HEALTH ITSELF
DOWN THE LINE THESE THESE COULD
LEAD TO INCREASED HEADACHES
DEPRESSION ANXIETY POOR MEMORY
YOUR ABILITY CONCENTRATION-
ISSUES- SUICIDE AND SO FORTH.
SO WHAT WHAT THIS BILL- WOULD
DO IT WOULD ASK OUR STATE
SURGEON GENERAL TO CONVENE A
COMMISSION. ON CTP AND YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL. TO INVESTIGATE
ISSUES RELATED TO THE RISKS OF
BRAIN INJURY. AND TO REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ANY FINDINGS
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE WHETHER OR
NOT THERE SHOULD BE A MINIMUM
AGE. TO PARTICIPATE IN YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL. YOU KNOW THERE
IS A MINIMUM AGE TO PER. AND
USED IN SMOKING FOR EXAMPLE WE
DON'T HAVE. A TWELVE YEAR OLD
SMOKE BY LAW WE ONE HAVE START
SMOKING FOR PREFERRED LET NO
ONE SHOULD SMOKE BUT- LAW WE
HAVE A CERTAIN HE'S DOING THAT-
THEY'RE NOT SAYING THERE SHOULD
BE A MINIMUM AGE THAT
CERTAINLY. HAS BEEN DEBATED
BEFORE IN THE PAST THIS WOULD
ASK OUR STAR SURGEON GENERAL OF
CALIFORNIA. TO RESEARCH THE
ISSUE AND GET BACK TO US- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION WITH
US TODAY I HAVE A PARENT WHO
HAS EXPERIENCED THIS- WITH-
HER- FAMILY MEMBER PLAYING
YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL. AS WELL
AS A LEADING RESEARCHER WITH
THE CONCUSSION LEGACY.
FOUNDATION AND- IN
MASSACHUSETTS THANK YOU BASS
SPEAKER MADAM CHAIR. OKAY SO WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND GO TO THE
WITNESSES AND ON THE PHONES.
FOR SHOULD I START I'M YES I
WILL JUST START WITH OK. OKAY
IS THAT OKAY- GOOD AFTERNOON
YEAH MY NAME IS JAN FRANKLIN.
MY SON AND ONLY CHILD JASON
DIED BY SUICIDE ON JULY
FOURTEENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN AT
THE AGE OF TWENTY SIX. MY
FRIEND WITH THE LIFE OF THE
PARTY HE HAD PERSONALITY AND
CHARM GALORE AND HE LOVED LIFE.
I GRADUATED COLLEGE AND WAS
JUST BEGINNING HIS MEDIA CAREER
WHEN THINGS STARTED TO GO AWRY.
I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING UNTIL IT WAS TOO
LATE. HE WAS HAVING HEADACHES
HE COULDN'T SLEEP HE SUDDENLY
BECAME WITHDRAWN HE WAS
THREATENING AND SHOW THE RAGE
I'D NEVER SEEN BEFORE. I TRIED
TO HELP THEM BUT THINGS HAPPEN
TO THAT. GESTURE AFTER HIS
DEATH THE CORONER IN ARIZONA
WHO WAS AWARE OF JASON'S
FOOTBALL HISTORY SUGGESTED WE
SENATE'S BRAIN. THE BOSTON
UNIVERSITY TO BE ANALYZED
PROCEEDING. JASON WAS DIAGNOSED
I'M SORRY GIPSON GRAYSON WAS
DIAGNOSED TO HAVE C. T. E.
STAGE TO. THE CITY IN DAMAGE
WAS ANALYZED AND WAS FOUND TO
BOTH BE MOSTLY IN THE ENVELOPE
OF THE BRAIN TO CONTROL IMPORTS
JUDGMENT BEILEIN'S AGGRESSIVE
BEHAVIOR DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDALITY. EVERYTHING WE
EXPERIENCE. SO WHY THIS
HAPPENED. MY SON STARTED
PLAYING TACKLE FOOTBALL AT THE
AGE OF ELEVEN SOME BOYS STARTED
AS YOUNG AS FIVE. LITTLE BOYS
CRASHING THERE HAD BEEN EACH
OTHER IN FACT THE FIVE YEAR OLD
TO BE THE HEAD FIVE HUNDRED
TIMES THIS SEASON FIVE HUNDRED
TIMES. AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH WOULD DAMAGE HIS BRAIN
UNTIL YEARS LATER. IN HONOR OF
MY SON WE CREATED A FIVE POUND
ISSUE BECAUSE I GOT YOU. TO
HELP THOSE IN NEED. UNDER THIS
PROGRAM WE'VE REACHED OUT TO
PLAYERS AND JASON TO LET THEM
KNOW THAT WE'RE HERE TO HELP
THEM. WE'VE HAD A FEW
CONTACTED. ONE PLAYER XANDER IS
STRUGGLING NOW WITH HEADACHES
AND DEPRESSION. HE STARTED
PLAYING TACKLE THE YOU. TO
OTHERS ONE OF MICHAEL ALSO HAVE
CONTACTED ME AS THEY ARE
CONCERNED THEY HAVE BUT THEY
ALSO STARTED ISSUES. THEY'RE
ALSO STRUGGLING WITH
DEPRESSION. WE NEED TO STOP
THIS. IF I KNEW THEN WHAT I
KNOW NOW I WOULD NEVER NEVER
HAVE LET MY SON PLAY YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL. PLEASE SUPPORT
AB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT. THE
SURGEON GENERAL COMMISSION
CONFIDE LEGISLATORS. AND
PARENTS WITH THE ISSUE
INFORMATION I WISH I HAD. YOU
WANT TO SEE HOW BY PROVIDE SON
WAS GO TO JASON FRANKLIN FIFTY
FIVE .COM WE'LL SEE. WHAT WE
LOST. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE. CHRIS
NOWINSKI PHD CO FOUNDER AND C.
E. O. OF CONCUSSION LEGACY
FOUNDATION. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HE SAID MY NAME IS DR CHRIS
NOWINSKI CO FOUNDER AND CEO OF
THE CONCUSSION LEGACY
FOUNDATION ALSO A CO FOUNDER OF
THE BOSTON UNIVERSITY CTE
CENTER FOR ELITE EDUCATION IN
PUBLIC POLICY EFFORTS. I HAVE A
PHD IN BEHAVIORAL NEUROSCIENCE
FROM BOSTON UNIVERSITY SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE PRODUCT TO OFFER MY
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT. OVER
THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS ROBUST
SCIENCE HAS DISCOVERED A STRONG
RELATIONSHIP. BETWEEN PLAYING
TACKLE FOOTBALL AND DEVELOPING
THE DGENERATIVE BRAIN DISEASE
CHRONIC TRAUMATIC
ENCEPHALOPATHY. THE DISEASE
THAT CAUSES PROBLEMS WITH
COGNITION AND YOUR BEHAVIORAL
DYSREGULATION AND EVENTUALLY
RESULT IN DEMENTIA. BOSTON
UNIVERSITY IN US DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS SCIENTISTS
RECENTLY PUBLISHED AN EX
FOOTBALL PLAYERS ODDS OF
DEVELOPING CTP INCREASE. 2230%
PER YEAR. THAT MEANS THAT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN FOOTBALL
AND DEVELOPING CTE MAY BE AS
STRONG AS THE LINK BETWEEN
SMOKING AND LUNG CANCER. AND TO
ME THAT MEANS THAT WE MAY WANT
TO THINK TWICE ABOUT EXPOSING
MORE CHILDREN TO THIS HARM.
JUST OF THE SURGEON GENERAL'S
REPORT HELP TO STOP UNNECESSARY
HARM FROM CIGARETTES I BELIEVE
THE CALIFORNIA SURGEON
GENERAL'S COMMISSION ON THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL C. T. WILL HELP
US CUT THROUGH. INDUSTRY
PROMOTED BAD SCIENCE AND
TALKING POINTS TO BUILD A
CONSENSUS REQUIRED TO MAKE
ADDITIONAL CHANGES TO YOU ALL
TO PROTECT CHILDREN. I'M NOT
AGAINST FOOTBALL I'M A FORMER
ALL IVY HARM FOOTBALL PLAYER
WHO KNOWS THE BENEFITS OF TEAM
SPORTS. BUT THE FACT IS HUMAN
BRAINS ARE NOT MEANT TO TAKE
THOUSANDS OF ITS OF ITS TO THE
HEAD. ESPECIALLY NOT THE BRAINS
OF CHILDREN WHEN THEY ARE
DEVELOPING. THE LAST DECADE
EVERY OTHER MAJOR TEAM SPORTS
AMERICA HAS REFORM TO THEIR
GAMES TO ELIMINATE PREVENTABLE
REPETITIVE HEAD IMPACTS FOR
KIDS. SOCCER'S BAND HEADING ICE
HOCKEY FAN CHECKING. WHAT
FOOTBALL IS STOCK PUTTING FOUR
POUND HELMETS ON FORTY POUND
CHILDREN BECAUSE THERE'S NO
NATIONAL GOVERNING BODY TO
ENFORCE REFORMS. THAT WERE UP
TO ME WHO HAS SEEN THE HARM
THAT FOOTBALL. CAN BRING TO THE
BRAINS OF NEARLY SEVEN HUNDRED
FOOTBALL PLAYERS INCLUDING
JASON FRANKLIN WHO STARTED. AT
OUR BRAVE BACK THE SPORT WOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED THREE YOUNG
CHILDREN. I BELIEVE THE SURGEON
GENERAL'S COMMISSION WILL HELP
INFORM BOTH PARENTS AND
LEGISLATORS ON THE RIGHT WAY TO
CHANGE YOU FOOTBALL TO PROTECT.
THE BRAINS AND FUTURES SHE ALL.
THANK THANK YOU BUT I WILL ASK
FOR ANY OR FOR THE COMMITTEE.
FROM AMERITRADE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARC MCCARTHY THANK YOU
ALL FOR THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
YOU BRING UP- TEAM OVERALL THE
CONCEPT DISCUSS RB SUPPORTING
BUT I DO HAVE A QUESTION- I YOU
KNOW- THE ESPECIALLY YOUNG
CHILDREN NOW- OF CLASHING
DEBATE HEADS TOGETHER OBVIOUSLY
IT'LL IMPACT OF. I WONDER- THAT
THERE HAS BEEN KNOWN SEVENTY AT
ALL SO THIS IS TO ESTABLISH A
COMMISSION TO STUDY SUCH AN
IMPACT ON THE PLANET GOT YOU
KNOW A DRAMATIC IMPACT THE
WHOLE OF THE CHILDREN WHEN.
ANNA K. F. A YOUNG US AFTER
LISTS ARE ARE INVOLVED-
OBVIOUSLY THERE WOULD BE I MEAN
I I'M ASSUMING THIS- THROUGH
ALL THE NEW SITE HERE AT THAT
THE BIG NEGATIVE IMPACT IS
THERE. BUT THE- IF AND WHEN IT
IS SET TURNED OUT TO BE-
DRAMATIC THE IMPACT- AND A
SUBSTANTIAL- PERCENTAGE OF- HE
HIGH SCHOOLER FOOTBALL PLAYERS
SELL WILL TURN OUT TO BE- NOT
IMPACT NEGATIVELY IMPACTED.
SEOUL ARE IS THERE ANY
POTENTIAL THAT THE HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL MAY BE BANNED IF
ASSIST TO FINDING A SAID
DISCLOSED. THANK YOU OUT I JUST
LIKE TO KNOW DOCTOR CHOI THAT
MY NEPHEW IS AN OUTSTANDING
HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL PLAYER IN
ORANGE COUNTY HE PLAYS FOR. IN
IRAN TO START SANTA MARGARITA
FOR- IS COPPER LAMA HIGH
SCHOOL. AND- HE- HE STARTED
PLAYING TACKLE FOOTBALL WHEN HE
WAS IN THE EIGHTH GRADE. AND SO
IF YOU WATCH THE SUPERBOWL A
FEW WEEKS AGO THIS THE WINNING
QUARTERBACK THE BEST
QUARTERBACK IN HISTORY AN NFL.
TOM BRADY DIDN'T START PLAYING
TACKLE FOOTBALL UNTIL HE WAS IN
HIGH SCHOOL SO IF I HAD MY WAY
AND I'M NOT SAYING AT THIS BILL
IS NOT THAT- YOU CAN YOU CAN
PLAY FOOTBALL AND LEARN ABOUT.
PASSING CATCHING BLOCKING IN
OTHER STUFF WITHOUT HAVING A
HELMET ON WHEN YOU'RE EIGHT
NINE TEN SOMETIMES SIX SEVEN
YEARS OLD UP TO THIRTEEN AND
START PLAYING TACKLE ONCE
YOU'RE IN HIGH SCHOOL SO THAT'S
WHAT I WOULD PREFER BUT THIS
BILL DOESN'T DO THAT. IT JUST
SAYS SHOULD THE SURGEON GENERAL
STUDY THIS ISSUE AND COME UP
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS ON-
APPROPRIATE AGE FOR YOUTH
PARTICIPATION. AND I THINK I
THINK THE SURGEON GENERAL- IS A
TALENTED INDIVIDUAL AND THEY'LL
BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THE PLATTER
OF RESEARCH IT'S OUT THERE ARE
READY. TO COME UP WITH SOME
EVALUATIONS BUT THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS NOW IS NOT GOING TO-
I DON'T THINK BANTOCK FOOTBALL
MANY PARENTS ARE WALKING WITH
THEIR FEET RIGHT NOW ANYWAY AND
THERE IS. FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER THIS MORE KIDS UNDER
TWELVE PLAYING FLAG FOOTBALL
THAN TACKLE AND THEN THEY CAN
SWITCH TO TALK WHEN THEY'RE
LITTLE OLDER BECAUSE- THEY'RE
THEY'RE MORE MATURE KIDS REACH
PUBERTY THEY HAVE THAT THE HEAD
NECK SHOULDERS THAT CAN HANDLE
THE HELMET THAT CAN HANDLE. THE
REPETITIVE HITS SO. FERIA
THANKS NOT IS A TOUGH DIGEST
DATA WILL HELP THROUGH OUR SET
UP BUT DIFFERENT- PRACTICE
POLICIES ASSESS ETCETERA SO I
THINK THAT THERE MAY BE SOME.
IN A MODIFIED THE PRACTICE THAT
DEPEND UPON THE DATA THAT IS
BEING COLLECTED I THINK THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT A STUDY. AT
THE UPPER PORTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOMED. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND TO THANK YOU MR MCCARTY FOR
BRINGING US SO WHAT I THINK IS
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL AND IT-
RELATES TO- SOMETHING I THINK
THE VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR-
AMERICANS AND CALIFORNIANS AND
THAT'S EFFECTIVE WE- ON A
VARIETY OF FRONTS DO NOT. DO A
VERY GOOD JOB ON THE ISSUE OF
PREVENTION. OF WE DON'T DO
ENOUGH ON PREVENTION FOR
EXAMPLE OF PREVENTING PEOPLE
FROM BECOMING HOMELESS OF WE
DON'T DO ENOUGH TO PREVENT
WILDFIRE. AND WHEN IT COMES TO
HEALTH CARE. OF ISSUES. LIKE
DIABETES AND HEART DISEASE SENT
TO MANY OTHER DISEASES- OF THAT
IN MANY CASES ARE ENTIRELY FOR
PREVENTABLE. WE DON'T DO MUCH
THIS IS YET ANOTHER- AND VERY
IMPORTANT AREA- WHERE THESE
HEAD INJURIES- ARE. ALMOST
ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE- AND- SO
THIS THIS BILL. AS YOU JUST A
VERY ELOQUENTLY- STATED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- GOES A LITTLE
BIT IN THAT DIRECTION- IT
DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH AND IN MY
VIEW BUT- I THINK IT IS GOOD
THAT IT ASKS THE SURGEON
GENERAL WHO ARE CLEARLY IS VERY
CAPABLE OF- PUTTING TOGETHER-
THAT THE MINES THAT ARE NEEDED
TO LOOK INTO THIS ISSUE MORE
DEEPLY AND COME OUT WITH A SET
OF RECOMMENDATIONS AND I HOPE
THAT THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
WILL. LEAD US TO A DAY WHERE WE
DON'T TO SEE THE KINDS OF
TRAGEDY- THAT OUR WITNESS SPOKE
UP IN THE- MANY OTHER CHILDREN
WHO HAVE SUFFERED AND IN MANY
CASES LOST THEIR LIVES BECAUSE
OF OUR FAILURE TO TAKE ACTION
ON THIS VERY PREVENTABLE-
CIRCUMSTANCE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AND I'M
OF THE BILL. WE'VE GOT A MOTION
AND A SECOND AND THEY BELIEVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND NAZARIAN
DID YOU WANNA MAKE A PROMISE I
JUST WANTED TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR'S WORK I THINK IN THE
PREVIOUS YEARS WHEN YOU BROUGHT
OF THE DIFFERENT BILL BUT
SIMILARLY. ORIENTED IN
TARGETING WHAT YOU WERE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH- I HAD AUTHORED
CO AUTHORED IT WITH YOU OR AND
I KNOW THAT I SUPPORTED IT SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR STEADFAST
WORK ON THIS ISSUE I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL AND I THINK IT'S ONE
OF THOSE ISSUES THAT. AS MANY
THINGS HERE THAT WE WORK ON WE
NEED TO CONTINUOUSLY BE THE
ADVOCATES TO EDUCATE OUR
CONSTITUENCIES AS WELL SO THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS WHAT IT IS
EXACTLY WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH- AND HOW WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP- ARE
CONSTITUENCIES IN SPECIALLY
THOSE AMONGST US THAT- MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO DETERMINE FOR
THEMSELVES WHAT IS GOING TO BE
FOR THEIR- BEST. INTEREST IN
THE FUTURE FOR THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU AGAIN. AND THIS BILL
IS A DO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS BY TWO AS THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AM
VERY. MUCH INTERESTED IN THIS
TOPIC ON NOT ONLY ON THE
SURGEON GENERAL CONVENING A
COMMISSION ON CHRONIC DRAMATIC-
BONTA SAID THAT WORD AGAIN AS-
SIMPLE. AS A FOLLOW UP THE P.
AT BUT YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS AS AN EDUCATOR MYSELF.
IS WE DO THINGS. AS EDUCATORS
THAT WERE TAUGHT TO DO AND
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO UNDO
THINGS AS WE LEARN MORE
INFORMATION SO I THINK THIS
WILL BE A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO HEAR WITH THE SURGEON
GENERAL. HAS TO SAY ALONG WITH
THE COMMISSION AND TO TAKE THAT
INFORMATION AND- PERHAPS THERE
WILL BE A CHANGE I CERTAINLY
DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR IS AT
ALL IS TRYING TO STATE. THAT
THERE WILL BE A BAN ON
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL- BUT I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD OPPORTUNITY STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION SO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND- MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU. CALL THE
ROLL. AB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT
MCCARTY. DO YOU PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUICK SILVA HI QUICK SILVA I BY
THE DENNIS. OF THE DENTIST I
BLOOM. BLOOM I TO. CHOI CHOI I
FRIEDMAN THIS AREA HI NAZARIAN
HI. EIGHTY THE KEY AND THEN FOR
THOSE OF YOU WATCHING US WE DO
HAVE MEMBERS GOING FROM
COMMITTEE TO COMMITTEE THERE
SEVERAL COMMITTEES GOING ON SO
SOME OF OUR MEMBERS ARE AND
OTHER COMMITTEE EASY THEY'RE
PRESENTING- WE NEED I HAVE A
FILE ITEM THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS A SHE IS ON HER WAY HERE
FOUND. FIRE UP YOUR BILL UP.
NOT HOTELS WAITING. UP SO.
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE MEMBERS
YEAH I THINK. AS A STATE DOCTOR
CHOI GOT HIS BELONGS. YOUR.
YEAH. WITH. TWENTY THREE TO
FIFTY SEVEN DEGREES I THOUGHT
THAT SEVEN FOR THE REPUBLIC
MAKING A PERSONAL. WORKING WITH.
OKAY STERN NINE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO VOTE ON AB THREE FIVE IF
IT'S AVAILABILITY YES. HI AB
FIVE CHILD MISSOURI HI. THANK
YOU.
A MUCH MORE. YEAH YEAH
SACRAMENTO GET. VERY. SEVENTY
CAN GET FROM THAT YEAH. OKAY.
YOU CAN HAVE A FIVE THE DEFENSE
BUDGET BUT I'M USUALLY COMMA OR
WHAT- OF THE DOOR. FIVE THIRTY.
OKAY YEAH YEAH. ON THURSDAY.
YEAH.
WHAT'S UP WITH. WORKING
ON IT. CORDNER AND HERE WE HAVE
BUSY BUSY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
PRESENTING FILE ITEM THREE AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE CHILDREN AND
INTERNET. SAFETY PLATFORM
OPERATORS AND WELCOME THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
APOLOGIES FOR BEING LATE. AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE TICKETS
AFTER LEVINE PRACTICAL
REMINDING HIM ONLINE CONTENT
THAT IS SPECIFICALLY DIRECTED.
THIS BILL REQUIRES PLATFORMS AS
DEFINED TO ALLOW PARENTS OR
GUARDIANS TO CREATE THAT
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR CHILDREN
WHICH- FINED BY UNDER THE AGE
OF THIRTEEN- THAT BY DEFAULT
NOT ALLOW AUTO PLAYING. IN APP
PURCHASES FROM HER CEMEX
CONTENT OR COMMUNICATE WITH
OTHERS ON THE PLATFORM. THIS
OFTEN PROVISIONAL PROVIDE
PARENTS WITH A LAYER OF CONTROL
SOMEONE THEIR CHILDREN'S ACCESS
PLATFORMS FEATURES THAT WERE
DESIGNED FOR ADULTS. AND
THEREFORE NOT FAR FROM THE
BUILDINGS AND SENSIBILITIES OF
YOUNG MINDS. AB FIFTEEN FORTY
FIVE ALSO PROHIBITS
ADVERTISEMENTS RELATED TO
ALCOHOL TOBACCO PRODUCTS
CONTAINING NICOTINE CONTENT AND
CONTENT DIRECTLY KIDS. REQUIRES
VISUAL INDICATORS TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN COMMERCIAL
AND NON COMMERCIAL CONTENT.
FROM AB FIFTEEN TWENTY FIVE
WELL APPOINTED CORPORATION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO AUDIT
PLATFORMS COMPLIANCE WITH
CURRENT CURRENT FEDERAL. AND
STATE FIVE CHILDREN'S PRIVACY
LAWS. I HAVE MY WITNESS- JOSEPH
JEROME DIRECTOR FOUGHT FROM
ACCOUNTABILITY AND FIGURE OUT
IF YOU COMMONSENSE MEDIA ONLINE.
TESTIFYING OKAY AND WILL GO AND
TAKE THAT THE COMMENTARY. JOE.
MISTER MODERATOR DO WE HAVE-
OUR SUPPORT WITNESS JOSEPH
JEROME. YEAH OKAY. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR THAT THE BILL. GOT
A MOTION TO MOVE IN A SECOND-
THAT LET ME CHECK IN ONE MORE
TIME DO WE HAVE- OUR SUPPORT
WITNESS JOSEPH JEROME- ONLINE.
A WILL WAIT WILL GIVE THAT JUST
A FEW SECONDS AND SEE IN THE
MEAN TIME DO WE HAVE ANY-
QUESTIONS- FOR. THE AUTHOR HERE.
SO HOW DID YOU TO PUSH. EXERT
PRESSURE OKAY YEAH CAN IN THERE
OF THE CASHIER THEY DIDN'T HEAR
ANY OF THAT. ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PHONES AND SEE
IF WE HAVE OUR SUPPORT WITH
WITNESS JOSEPH JEROME. ALL
RIGHT WELL JUST TO REPEAT AS WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND WE
HAVE HEARD THE BILL WERE
WAITING TO SEE IF WE HAVE A
SUPPORT WITNESS. IN THE
MEANTIME WE ARE GOING TO SEE IF
WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS WITH
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. THE SAME
NONE THEN WE WILL TRY FOR THE
OPPOSITION WITH YES. THE
WITNESSES SAYING THERE ON THE
LINE. CAN WE GO AHEAD AND SEE
IF WE CAN GET THE WITNESS SAW
ON. AND ELLO MADAM CHAIR THAT
THAT IS THE OPERATOR- IF YOUR
WITNESS FOR THIS BILL ON THE
PHONE PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO SO
WE CAN IDENTIFY YOUR LIFE.
THREE AND I HAVE DILLON
HOFFMAN- A POLL ON THE LINE.
AND SHOP MOHAMMED. JOSEPH
FRIEDMAN ALL RIGHT SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE OPPOSITION TO GO
BACK TO SUPPORT AT THE END IF
WE CAN GET THAT PERSON ON SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND START WITH
JOB MUHAMMAD. R. MISTER
MODERATOR WILL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE THE OPPOSITION WITH SHAH
MUHAMMAD. OR DILLON HAFEN
WHICHEVER ONE WE CAN GET. HAVE
BOTH IDENTIFIER. HI MANAGER
KEVIN HOFFMAN CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SPEAKING DEL HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNET
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS REALLY
LIKE TO- EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR TO
CONTINUE REFINING THIS BILL-
OUR COMPUTERS ARE STILL
REVIEWING THE MOST RECENT
LANGUAGE BUT- HAPPY TO REPORT
THERE ANOTHER POSITIVE STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION- MOLD
LIKELY HAVE SOME TECHNICAL
PRODUCTION PROTECT UP SOME OF
THE BILL TERMS- BUT WE CAN
BETTER OPERATIONALIZE AND
ENSURE COMPLIANCE BUT AGAIN WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION AS FAR THE AUTHOR
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH HER AND. HER STAFF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ARE A NEXT- EITHER SHOW THAT
MUHAMMAD. YES I'M HERE. WELCOME.
THANK YOU BUT OF COURSE THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS- SHORT MOM
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND- WE'RE CURRENTLY
STILL OPPOSED TO IT THE FIFTEEN
FORTY FIVE BUT I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THAT IMPROVE INTO
THE BILL AND- WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS CONTINUE
ENGAGEMENT WITH US ON THAT
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON
REVIEWING AND THAT MEANT- WITH
THE GOAL OF PROVIDING THE
OFFICE OFFICE WITH ADDITIONAL
FEEDBACK FROM OUR MEMBERS BUT I
WANT TO DO AGAIN IS NOT THE
AUTHOR THE AUTHOR STOPPING
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS. FOR
THEIR CONTINUED WORK ON THIS
BILL AND WE. LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH DEFERRED THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR
HAS BEEN WORKING NOT.
EFFECTIVELY ON ON MAKING SURE.
THAT YOU'RE LISTENING TO THEIR
CONCERNS. LET'S SEE IF WE GOT
IF WE HAVE. JOSEPH JEROME. FOR
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT WELL WE WILL
GET BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS- BEFORE WE GO AHEAD
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
AND THIS IS- DO PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS AND
I TO- KNOW THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS BILL IF YOU
STATED AND- I WILL SAY ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT- IS INTERESTING
TO ME AS I HAVE OLDER CHILDREN
WAY OVER THIRTEEN BUT THERE IS
SO MANY NEW DEVICES OUT THERE
THAT ARE UNDER THAT QUOTE
TOLLWAY CATEGORY. THAT CAN YOU
JUST EXPLAIN ADAM PLAY BECAUSE
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO AGE ME
BUT EXACTLY WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
SURE- APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
BASICALLY IT LETS THINGS KEEP
PLAYING OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN AND IN CERTAIN
PLATFORMS LIKE YOU TUBE THERE'S
ALGORITHMS THAT SEND KIDS FROM
WATCHING ONE SPECIFIC THING TO
A WHOLE DIFFERENT OTHER SET OF
CONTENT- THAT COULD BE WILDLY
DIFFERENT AND WHEN YOU LET YOUR
KID WATCH AT THE VERY BEGINNING
YOU END UP IN A VERY DIFFERENT
PLACE- SO IT'S TRYING TO THE
BILL RELEASE TRYING TO GIVE
PARENTS MORE TOOLS. AND AGAIN
IF PARENTS WANT TO OPT IN AND
ALLOW THEIR KIDS TO DO THAT
THAT'S FINE BUT WE WANT TO GIVE
PARENTS MORE TOOLS THAT'S THE
PARENTAL CHOICE BUT MORE TOOLS
TO SORT OF GRAPPLE WITH HOW WE
MANAGE CHILDREN'S EXPERIENCE
ONLINE- AND ALSO THINGS LIKE
THE IN APP PURCHASES- AGAIN
PARENTS CAN OPT IN IF THEY WANT
THEIR KIDS TO GO NUTS AND BUY
ALL KINDS OF STUFF ON THESE
THESE APPS- BUT WE WANT TO GIVE
THE PARENTS THE CHOICE TO BE
ABLE. TO PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING IF THEY SO CHOOSE.
WHERE IS THAT YOU'RE CLOSE IN
WITH SAID CLASS FOR AN AYE VOTE
ALL RIGHT- AND WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE IT MADAM SECRETARY. AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FIVE WICKS. D.
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUICK SILVA HI
QUICK SILVA ONLINE BY THE
DENNIS. BALLOT THAT IT'S NOT
VOTING BLOOM. BLOOM ONLINE TO.
CHOI CHOI NOT VOTING MAN
FRIEDMAN NINE AREA HI NAZARIAN
HI. AND YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THAT IS OUR
THREE BILLS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
WE GOT FROM M. M. OUT WE NEED
TO GO BACK THROUGH THE ROLE
HERE YEAH. YEAH AB THIRTY FIVE.
CHIU TO CHILD TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN.
MAIENSCHEIN AB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT MCCARTY. D. PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN HI. AND THEN
WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR MR TRUMP
CHU HE WOULD LIKE TO VOTE YES
THANK YOU KEEP- THE ROLE OPEN
AT IS MR CHUAN ISRAEL WAY. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL KEEP THE ROLES OPEN
FOR FIVE MINUTES.
NOT DIRECTLY.
THAT IS GOING TO END OUR
HEARING TODAY. HAVE A GREAT DAY.